I now have enough philosophy related
questions to do another 10 shorts
answering some of these and I actually
have some leftovers as well so keep the
questions coming in and I will compile
them into sequences of 10 and and answer
them and put them out like this so in
the meantime here are 10 questions a bit
all over the map there is some sort of
unity or structure to what we're talking
about here but you'll have to figure
that out on your own
here's an interesting question from
someone named amez was Aristotle a
virtuous man and if he was was he happy
so to answer the second part first if
we're using Aristotle's own conceptions
of happiness and virtue if he was
virtuous then he probably was happy
happiness for Aristotle includes a bit
more than just merely having burch you
have to exercise virtue it has to be
active and that requires that you have
friends and companions and possibly
family that you're you know circles that
you're connected with Aristotle had that
it also requires that you have
sufficient means for for two reasons one
is if you're totally dirt poor you can't
be happy you're going to be too
vulnerable to the vicissitudes of
fortune to be actually happy but you
also need wealth or property or goods in
order to actually exercise some of the
virtues so did Aristotle have that he
did the question that we want to figure
out that is was he actually virtuous
Aristotle divides virtue into the moral
virtues which most people tend to focus
on and on the intellectual virtues and
clearly he had developed the
intellectual virtues that he discusses
in immuno nikka mccain ethics book six
did he have the moral virtues that he
discusses in nikka mccain ethics and you
Damien ethics and politics rhetoric and
all these other works I think you can
make a good case that is that he did we
don't know an awful lot about his is
biography not as much as we'd like to
know but in order to really be able to
analyze virtue the way that he did you
have to be a keen observer of human
nature and you you at least have to be
on the way to virtue if not actually
possess them to be able to engage in the
kind of groundbreaking analysis that he
did
so another Aristotle question this one
is from rude ranch moondellah and he
says do you do you think that Aristotle
was right to believe that the final goal
or end of all rational action is the
achievement of a happy that is you
demoniac life and yes I do think he's
right about that as a matter of fact I
am an Aristotelian in that sense at some
other senses as well but I think that
you have to be careful in understanding
some of these terms so is Aristotle
right in thinking that the final goal or
end of all rational action is eudaimonia
in the sense that he is talking about he
thinks that a lot of people are actually
wrong in their conception of happiness
that they pursue the wrong things they
are engaged in reasoning processes but
they they're you know going from some of
the wrong premises towards the wrong
ends because they've misconceived
happiness so you know not everybody
understands fully what you did I ammonia
is and if we sort of shoot a head to
people like Thomas Aquinas they would
say even Aristotle managed to
misunderstand some of the nature
eudaimonia so in in broad sense I'm in
agreement with Aristotle that when we're
actually well informed properly
functioning less messed up than we
typically are we made some progress then
eudaimonia in you know the full sense of
satisfying everything that you know is
within our nature leading us to our
highest realization yes then that is the
sort of motivator for everything there's
a lot of ways to go off the beaten path
actually not even off the beaten path
will off the path yet they beaten
towards eudaimonia and I think Aristotle
is very attuned to that the thumbnail
sketches that you get of Aristotle don't
adequately
capture that
here's a question about play-doh by bora
atole how can we get out of Plato's cave
in this life is it by death well that's
an interesting thing to ask so if you
were to be looking say just at the
Phaedo or you know if the Phaedo with
some of the other beat up dialogues like
the apology then you might say yeah that
that sounds about right because you know
what is Plato's cave it's this realm of
sensible appearances where the things
are material we experience them through
the bodily senses and we're tied down to
the body which is the coffin of the soul
right so death as liberation to then go
you know off to the the world of the
forms and actually see them finally
unmixed unalloyed with any sort of
material whatever it is material you
know shape copy who knows yeah that that
would be one way to do it but if you're
looking at say the Republic Plato's
laying out a whole program well you know
not in complete detail but a program by
which people would be able to come out
of the cave and you know if you think
about the metaphor the the allegory of
the cave they don't kill the guy and say
all right reincarnate someone else or
you know just you know don't reincarnate
just hang out with the forms instead
they break his shackles they lead him
out of the cave he's you know unhappy
the whole time he has to accustom
himself through a lot of disciplined
paying attention to what's actually in
front of him and then he's actually able
to be truly out of the cave when he can
see things and perceive the the light of
the Sun that's done in this life that
occurs through education not education
in the sense that we tend to do it but
education in the holistic sense of
dealing with the entire person and it's
a long process
so Demetri andreyev asks a question
which has to do with existentialist
authors and I know there's maybe
somebody was going to say come who
wasn't an existentialist a really
actually was depends on how you're going
to define it and he asks where are you
in the opposition between lab chest off
and all we're coming because chest off
in many respects out Kierkegaard's
Kierkegaard he is the you know the
person making the leap par excellence
according to to Albert combo he's not
that well-known but he's a really
brilliant existentialist thinker and
he's clearly a theistic existentialist
thinker all you got to do is read you
know some of his early works or read you
know Athens and Jerusalem to get a
clearer sense of that Camus hardcore
atheist thinker about as far along that
spectrum as you can possibly get i would
say that in many respects he is an even
better representative of that than
Sartre is or de pouvoir and Camus
criticizes chest off for and the other
as he calls them existentialists for
acknowledging the absurd but then not
remaining true to it by remaining within
the scope of our experience being you
know okay with human reasons revelation
to us that the world essentially sucks
and is not going to conform to what we
need it to be and then revolting against
it he says that they they make a leap
they make the absurd into God and
thereby they kind of pulled the fangs
out of it I think come was wrong I think
he misinterpreted the theistic
existentialist I think that there's
something to come lose position but I i
think that the existential start making
the sort of leap that he's talking about
that instead they're they're doing
something much more
what God real Marcel was talking about
in terms of mystery is experience absurd
or is experience mysterious that's the
question for tribes essentialism
another existentialist question by
Christopher Dunn can Sartre be
considered a substance duelist with his
ideas of being for itself and being in
itself so let's review a little bit say
that somebody's a substance duelist
means that there's there like Descartes
or there like like you know lesser
extent like play-doh because material
things aren't really substances for him
so Descartes right you have extension
body can be perceived can be cut up you
know bodies can't penetrate each other
then you have a thought the other type
of substance and you know or you might
say body in mind and the question is how
do you get these together so for decart
the answers the pineal gland and there's
a whole complicated story there the idea
is that there's two basic kinds of
things and somehow they interact but
they're really distinct from each other
they can be understood and distinct from
each other what is being in itself and
being for itself for cert is it that
sort of thing no being in itself is just
being and it's the sort of plenitude of
what is there is no negativity to it
it's being for itself which is reflexive
which is able to take account of itself
which actually brings in negativity and
engages in it takes this word from high
to your knee halation takes negative
attitudes towards things so it also
takes a negative attitude towards itself
and I don't mean like you know negatives
and pejorative but rather it is not what
it is so it's not a substance the for
itself is not a substance in a certain
way you could see it as coming out of
the in itself as one of the
possibilities for the in itself which
then can sort of reflect on everything
else no this is not a substance dualism
art is trying to actually get away from
substance dualism it is dualistic but
it's not a substance dualism
so here's another interesting sard
question is being a nothingness a
serious work or is it a joke or is it
supposed to create an impressionistic
sense of approximation not certainty
this is by Jay Ingham and so let me say
from the start it is a serious work and
like all serious works if you want to
understand it you probably have to put
in a lot of time and work to understand
what the author is saying requires
reading rereading studying went back and
forth till you can actually see what it
is that they're they're driving at no
it's not a joke as a matter of fact Sark
was not a particularly funny guy when I
comes down to it very few of the X of
the the atheistic existentialists seemed
to have had a great sense of humor is it
supposed to be give you an
impressionistic sense of approximation I
don't even know what that would mean by
that are you saying that that he is sort
of like throwing stuff up on the wall
and seeing whether you know it turns
into something or you know just like
giving some vignettes no he's engaging
in serious phenomenological analyses of
human you know human life and its
condition and he's engaged in
metaphysical analysis as well of what
our type of being is what other types of
beings are I think he's one of based on
a lot of things but it's it's meant to
be a serious and actually systematic
work there's a question at the end you
know not certainty well yes and no I
mean Sartre thinks that if you accept
the basic ideas that he's beginning with
which he thinks are derived from
experience you can be certain about some
things in that work not everything but
he thinks that he's actually on track
with with a lot of these things that
said the drive for certainty that
obsesses so many people I think
oftentimes it's sort of a superficial
level of certainty that they want
rather than what you get by actually
exploring great great works
so here's a question by zero she flies
what do you think in general of Karl
poppers critique of Hegelian dialectics
so I'm glad that he asked me in general
for two reasons one is that it's been a
long time since I've actually read
popper and i'll talk about why in just a
second the other is that i don't really
want to get into the details of poppers
you know critique if you want to call it
that i would actually call just a
polemic but you know but popper is not
somebody who i read much of you know or
looked at in the last really ten years i
had to read quite a bit of him back in
graduate school and I was highly
unimpressed with what I read in part
because he seemed to have such a tin ear
for understanding other thinkers and
that's always a bad sign for me if you
if you need to distort you know other
thinkers and sort of like bring them
down to your level you know that's
because your levels can alone and I
understand you guys he was you know made
into a night and great contributions to
the philosophy of science and you know
that's fine as soon as he starts
straying outside of the philosophy of
science the Natural Sciences I think his
stuff just you know isn't very good what
I do recall of having read his
discussions of Hegel in the open society
and its enemies was you know being
struck by just how how much he twisted
what he took from Hegel to make it fit
these these preconceived notions that he
had and also being struck by you know
was i'm reading him like wow some people
are really going to get off on this some
people are really going to love this
sort of thing there's there's stuff that
you can criticize Hagel for you know i
think that that poppers criticisms
aren't the really good criticisms that
we can make
Hagel
so here's another interesting question
about another classic thinker and
classic work and in what we could call
analytic philosophy who most analytics
don't read anymore today what a wife
what is my opinion on the merits of the
Tractatus logi co philosophic asst that
is a little bit viccon Stein's early
work I I don't see it as a I don't see
it as an important contribution to to
understanding philosophy but it is
interesting to look at it's interesting
in the same sort of project way like
like Spinoza's ethics is interesting to
me I don't again I don't it's not
something that I say wow this is wow
this is where I want to go with anything
and even vikander Stein later outings
like yeah that work I was really off
base in quite a bit of it you know the
picture theory that I was using it's
interesting that somebody would write it
it's interesting to look at it's sort of
like playing around with a crystal is
guy you know I used to really be into
logic and the foundations of mathematics
and so that was a work that I went over
a lot and you know I could read the
German so I was always like this
translation isn't quite exact but how
are we can convey this so it's more like
a puzzle piece than than anything else I
think it is great as far as pedagogy
goes that students should be exposed to
this and that they should spend some
time lingering with it if it was going
to be your view of the world I probably
would not want to have you as an
interlocutor because I would find most
of what what you would say very boring
and hard to you know fit anything else
in i mean if if you've got this that
they're of you know which we cannot
speak we must be silent there's all this
unit is act like mysticism well you know
let's read some actual mystics that it's
much more interesting to read them than
you know these little aphorisms but you
know like i said it's it's a great thing
for people to be exposed to as they go
through the history
a philosophy as they're engaging in
their formation I just don't think that
it's a resting place of any sort
here's a question by mark smith is there
much exposure to african philosophy in
north america and europe and if so is it
an african interpretation of Western
thought or could it be seen as something
more uniquely African so my experience
with this is kind of scatter shot I'm
not an expert on this I've taught
african-american philosophy classes
before I had incorporate some things
from some of the classic you know text
in in you know african philosophy
whatever that's going to mean like you
know John the beauties stuff when I was
teaching world religions to talk about
indigenous religions of Africa and I
can't speak for Europe I can speak for
for North America here's my impression
first of all if most people aren't
usually talking just in terms of african
philosophy or african american
philosophy they like to talk in terms of
Africana philosophy because then it can
like cover all this stuff and includes
the caribbean authors as well what tends
to sell is not so much african
incorporation of european thought as you
know sort of reconstructions of what you
know ought to be african thought or you
know its diaspora you know stuff but you
know phan own is is a good example of
something to get cited quite a bit and
you know you can go to conferences and
see people doing things at him here's my
impression in the States if there is any
presence of this sort of stuff in
philosophy departments it's just in a
very token way and it's not taken
particularly seriously although it
probably does deserve to be taken more
seriously but that's because of the
composition of current philosophy a lot
of it gets done outside of philosophy
departments in English departments or
history departments or cultural studies
or area studies or things like that
so we finish up with a set of questions
from Andrew the red one about an R and
and he says do i sear and receiving more
attention in the future how she viewed
your colleagues and students where does
she fit within the philosophical
territory so there's a legacy ran being
just ignored or marginalized or
demonized within academia in part
because many academics are pretty
liberal and she not only lent herself to
conservative causes you know quite
understandably because it's what she
actually thought now she's you know very
identifiable as a libertarian a
particular type and so there's a clash
there there's like a long history of
dismissing her and so the leads to this
cycle of well you can't possibly think
that there could be anything there which
is really you know typical stupidity on
the part of many academics that said you
know when you actually run into people
who are really like Rand enthusiasts
some of them are pretty fringe pretty
out there and they love throw around
words like logic and reason and stuff
like that and a lot of that does
substitution for actual use of logic and
reason I'm not endorsing either side of
this by the way so does she you know
does she deserve to actually have a
place at the table in terms of
philosophy i would say i'd say yes and
there have been recent works by serious
academic scholars not ran devotees who
have been making the case that you know
no she's you know here's some ideas in
hers let's let's actually look at them
and let's compare them to some other
thinkers let's take this seriously the
trouble is when we do that we usually
find out that she she has some stuff to
offer but she's not a first-rate
philosopher she's certainly not the one
that you should orient everything around
and take as the authoritative word on
anybody else's philosophy how is she
viewed by my colleagues and students so
most of my colleagues of course you know
nothing good ever came from Rand
my students don't know that much about
her but they're interested they're
inquisitive and I think she is going to
be better known in the future in part
because academia is kind of withering
traditional academia has to engage the
broader world and she's part of the
broader conversations